i
hola buenas tardes cómo están listos
muy bien bueno pues esta charla es
justamente porque tener
estudiar el futuro porque esto también
se puede
justamente es porque el futuro
y es lo que importa
la velocidad de los cambios es tan
grande
que no podemos controlar ni anticipar
tantas cosas y por eso es que hoy se
vuelve primordial que nosotros podamos
saber que futuros puede haber qué
consecuencias van a tener estos futuros
y además de eso qué decisiones vamos a
tomar hoy
y si justamente lo dije en plural
estamos hablando de futuros porque la
noticia es que no existe un solo futuro
oficial hay varios tipos de futuros aquí
vamos a ver una variedad de ellos no los
primeros y los que más nos gustan son
los futuros preferibles a los futuros
deseables es todo esto que nosotros
queremos y lo que deseamos no pero junto
con ellos existen futuros posibles
por ciertas características del entorno
tienen
altas posibilidades de que sucedan
independientemente de nosotros
otros se llaman
probables y estos tienen que ver con
probabilística son muy parecidos a los
posibles
son aquellos que van a suceder a pesar
de nosotros y con nosotros y son a los
que debemos de poner atención porque ahí
están y están presentes y hay
información sobre ellos
los futuros potenciales normalmente son
aquellos que queremos evitar
porque no nos gusta no nos asustan más
sin embargo están ahí y van a suceder
entonces qué hacemos
como le hacemos para que sucedan los
preferibles justamente es a partir de
decisiones que tomemos hoy
esto de la futurología efectivamente
suena como algo esotérico a veces cuando
me dicen que eres futuróloga
o sea previstas el futuro
y la bola de cristal donde quedamos mi
capa así como de walter mercados no esto
no es así no está en el estudio futuros
es algo
mucha más fuerza
son pioneros ellos
de la parte en orden
a partir de estas metodologías
y es esto esta frase de gerard bergen
del albergue es un futurólogo de 1970 y
su frase hoy es vigente no y dice así
cuanto más veloz es un auto más lejos
deben abarcar sus luces para evitar
posibles daños y anticipar el peligro
eso es lo importante y justo hoy si van
a ver la película de ford versus ferrari
el piloto hay una parte donde dice
cuando tienes tan alta velocidad lo peor
que puedes hacer es ir así tienes que
hacer así no y justo es esto la analogía
es la luz es información cuando el
tiempo es tan veloz la información es
básica para saber tomar decisiones
anticipadamente porque yo puedo decidir
estar en el día a día efectivamente pero
me llega la curva y pues igual que
derrapó porque no la vi porque no preví
que tenía que bajar la velocidad igual y
la libró pero va a venir otra y en eso
tal vez me vuelque
que es importante aquí la información
si el futuro importa y como les digo no
se trata de predecir el futuro es tener
información donde va a haber algunos
niveles de certeza gracias a la
información pero otras cosas seguirán
siendo inciertas quien les diga que el
futuro se puede predecir con certeza no
es así entre más largo es el tiempo de
predicción más se abre la incertidumbre
mientras a decir bueno y entonces que se
trata esto sigue siendo igual de
complicado no no aquí les va el futuro
solo puede existir cuando se convierte
en el presente y es la paradoja del
futuro pero en ese punto deja de ser el
futuro del futuro es completamente
desconocido pero hay cosas en el
presente que sí sabemos y como que con
la frase a lo mejor no ayude mucho
porque seguimos en las mismas no bueno
es que es eso es una paradoja y lo que
pretendo es hacerles entender como las
dos cosas están unidas oye pero mejor
vivo al presente pues sí pero aunque no
quieras
te va a llevar a un futuro no entonces
si queremos que sea en base a nuestro
futuro deseable tendríamos que ser más
consciente de lo que hacemos y la buena
noticia es que el futuro se puede
diseñar y todos podemos diseñarlo
así cuando vivimos el día a día
normalmente esto me pasa cuando asesor o
organizaciones cuando asesoró a la
ciudad gobierno el pánico es tanto del
día a día y de la incertidumbre y de la
avalancha de cosas incontrolables porque
no están solamente implícito el mundo
interno que controlamos sino también un
mundo externo que nos está influenciando
y nos lleva hacia ciertas cosas que la
gente deja de querer pensar en el futuro
parece como ocioso o sea dices bueno
pero como si no ves que ahorita nos está
llevando a la fregada pues no no nos
están cuando la fregada y podemos salir
adelante no se podemos hacer muchas
cosas esto me lleva a explicar qué está
pasando hoy los sociólogos le llaman
danés a esta era los tiempos post
normales y por qué pues normal es bueno
porque hoy nada se comporta normal
porque normal implica un contexto y un
tiempo y hoy ese tiempo y contexto no es
el mismo
entonces no es mejor ni peor no es
diferente y es post normal como
identificamos si realmente son tiempos
normales y bueno son con tres es la
primera se es complejidad y la
complejidad tiene que ver que es la
primera vez donde en una misma era
convivimos varias generaciones con
puntos de vista que no son coincidentes
una generación z piensa muy distinto a
una generación x a un baby boomer
entonces encontrar puntos coincidentes
se vuelve una complejidad hay
complejidad en visiones entre países hay
quien apuesta a la apertura hay quien
apuesta a comercios cerrados etcétera
etcétera al liberalismo al conservar
conservas a entornos más conservadores
estos son la complejidad que hoy vivimos
esto parece que nos lleva al caos pero
la buena noticia es que en el caos hay
dos opciones
todos los sistemas se reorganicen y
mutan a cosas preferibles o pueden
colapsar y usted no decir bueno pues
cuál es el nuestro no a cual vamos bueno
eso me lleva a la tercer se la severidad
de las contradicciones que vivimos son
lo que nos mantiene en el caos en el
punto que podamos encontrar
coincidencias y no tratar de convencer
al otro sino encontrar en ese pequeño
punto que coincidimos es cuando vamos a
notar oye plantos cuánto tiempo vamos a
vivir el caos pues el tiempo que
tardemos en encontrar esos puntos
coincidentes no esto es así entonces
bueno si hoy tenemos que tomar
decisiones sobre el futuro en el
presente porque el futuro es algo real y
se va a ser tangible tarde que temprano
están atados
esta frase en cinco palabras lo dice
todo es de mi colegas ha de instalar y
la pongo ante ustedes porque tiene toda
la razón el futuro está presente en el
presente están unidos y bueno pues no
los voy a dejar ahí quiero compartir con
ustedes tres pasos donde todos podemos
empezar a entender el futuro diseñar el
futuro y lograr que sean futuros
preferibles
paso número 1 lo primero es empezar a
imaginar qué puede pasar y efectivamente
esta plataforma es para eso imaginemos
un 2040 pero él imagina tiene que tener
un cierto orden y para eso es imaginar
cosas con certeza imagina cosas con
incertidumbre analiza tendencias
todas estas tendencias tendencias
tendencias el paso número 1 es
verdaderamente hacer un escaneado de
tendencias y de tendencias creemos saber
pero sabemos pocas un verdadero escaneo
de un medio ambiente implica niveles de
percepción y los explico son tres
niveles de percepción que tendencias hay
en mi microambiente que a veces es yo
mismo mi sector mi organización mi
empresa
arriba de eso está un entorno medio del
cual yo tengo un poco de control pero no
si estuviéramos hablando de estas
ciudades la ciudad pero después el país
no y arriba de eso está un entorno
global que son las grandes tendencias
globales las tendencias globales tienen
mucho más influencia sobre lo que sucede
en nuestro mundo interno de lo que
creemos y de lo que podemos controlar
entonces esas son las tendencias que se
estudian no son de producto ahora ese es
un nivel de percepción en cuanto a
entorno pero el otro nivel de percepción
es en cuanto a tiempo son tendencias a
qué tiempo al 2020 son mañana que tanto
puedo anticipar al 2030 hay unas pero
tienen un nivel de incertidumbre al 2040
estamos hablando de evoluciones humanas
todavía hay más incertidumbre entonces
tenemos que ser conscientes de que
estamos analizando qué es realmente
hacer un escaneo de tendencias
esto es una clave para cuando empiecen a
hacerlo las tendencias no sangran a la
realidad no a lo que queremos que suceda
eso si pasa no llega y muestra algunas
tendencias y siempre no yo no creo que
eso pase a ver esto es con data tenemos
que hacer trabajo de una manera
profesional
no podemos solamente ver aquello que
brilla no las innovaciones tecnológicas
tienden a ser las tendencias que todos
vemos porque brillan porque están
tangibles pero debajo de ellas hay algo
que las provocó y eso es lo que tenemos
que empezar a entender por eso digo que
el paso número uno efectivamente es
empezar a imaginar el futuro pero es
esto esto qué va a pasar qué
consecuencias podría tener y no siempre
son catastróficas toda tendencia tiene
dos vertientes y es un árbol de
oportunidades y un árbol de riesgos
entonces tenemos que ser consciente no
entonces estos son los niveles de
percepción paso número 2 ok pero que me
gustaría a mí que pasara y si aquí tengo
que empezar a ver que no hay un futuro
oficial no estamos acostumbrados vamos a
escribir una misión y la ponemos en un
cuadrito y pues ese es el futuro oficial
para todos no hay futuros tenemos que
empezar a entender que hay más caminos
muy importante no pensemos en que
queremos hacer en función de que
queremos evitar no normalmente también
vemos tendencias que no nos gustan y
entonces yo lo que diseño son
estrategias para evitar tengo miedo a
todo lo que va a traer la tecnología
entonces trabajamos para evitar y
contrarrestar no también tengo que ver
qué puedo construir para ok entonces
esta es muy importante el paso número 3
es ok las tendencias me dicen que debo
hacer hacia dónde va el mundo
el otro paso es que quiero hacer ya
tengo dos cosas que confrontar el tercer
paso es con que cuento
y normalmente también tenemos una guerra
tenemos una guerra entre lo que quiero y
lo que puedo y lo que debo pues ya
entonces queda lejos porque está atado a
lo que puedo es que normalmente pensamos
lo que puedo con las herramientas que
hoy tengo en el presente pero esto no es
así se trata de qué herramientas tengo
que generar de cara al futuro a lo que
debo hacer esto se llama innovar para el
futuro innovación para el futuro
bueno con estos tres pasos ya puedo
hacer algo como esto ya puedo empezar a
tener una visión una visión por lo menos
tiene que tener un tiempo de 10 años la
gente que se dedica a esto te dice que
corto plazo son 10 años mediano plazo 15
20 y todavía nos podemos ir más allá no
entonces por lo menos 10 años en base a
esa visión efectivamente yo diseño
estrategias que me ayuden a lograr la
visión y efectivamente puedo ejecutar
tácticas y cada unas tienen un periodo
de tiempo ahora pero el camino no es una
línea recta esto no me va a llevar
directamente a esto ni a esto ni
viceversa o sea realmente todo se mueve
de manera que no podemos tener tanto
control la serra
las tendencias son sistémicas se
relacionan unas con otras y por eso
tenemos que aprender a verlas y
monitorear su evolución
la palabra es anticipar la anticipación
nos ayuda a justamente a estar cómodos
en la incertidumbre por eso les decía
que el futuro no se trata de predecir
porque no vamos a lograr tener una
certeza lo que vamos a lograr con
información con esa luz con de esos
grandes faros es poder anticipar es
poder estar cómodos en la incertidumbre
y créanme que esto es muy importante la
velocidad tan vertiginosa de los cambios
hoy nos genera a las personas
muchísima ansiedad y atrás de la
ansiedad es porque hay una gran cantidad
de desconocimiento de lo que sucede
entonces justamente la luz es esta
información y nos dejara estar cómodos y
cómodos con la incertidumbre
prospectiva significa justamente como
incluimos el conocimiento pasado el
conocimiento presente y como imaginamos
el futuro es una guía para poder
desarrollar visión
no es fácil hacer prospectiva hoy tengo
el honor y la gran oportunidad de
participar en la revisión de la visión
de esta ciudad al 20 45 y es la primera
vez que hacemos un trabajo de diseño de
escenarios alternativos justamente a
partir de un entorno global que va a
impactar el desarrollo de esta ciudad no
solamente lo que sucede en el país sino
también fuera del país y esto es
prospectiva y son cosas nuevas que
realmente ayudan a que hoy podamos tener
estrategias escenarios tableros de
control que nos ayuden a anticipar
muchas situaciones y no a vivir
reaccionando
porque fallamos porque falla la
prospectiva una es porque si con las
tendencias siempre creemos que el cielo
se nos está cayendo como digo las vemos
como amenazas y no como oportunidades
entonces aprendamos a ver esto la
segunda es porque amamos los procesos
lineales y en los tiempos normales eso
no existe acuérdense nada se va a
comportar normal entonces la línea recta
para llegar de un punto a un punto b va
a tener un montón de vertientes un
montón de curvas y un montón de detalles
que la influencia y me hagan cambiar por
eso tengo que tener varios escenarios y
varios futuros y anticipar la tercera es
porque operamos en silos normalmente los
departamentos encargados de hacer
prospectiva de análisis son un
departamento justamente y cuando van y
los presentan el resto del equipo es de
donde la sacaron pero mira si yo he
visto otras si yo he revisado otras este
es un proceso que tiene que ser integral
tenemos que hacerlo entre más
porque las visiones son encontradas y
cómo diseñar un futuro es a partir de la
visión de muchas personas
la corta ese es porque observamos
únicamente la punta del iceberg
como les decía aquellas tendencias que
nos emocionan o que nos asustan o las
innovaciones tecnológicas pero esas son
consecuencia de algo que está abajo cuál
es la evolución de valores del futuro
cuáles van a ser los cambios sociales
que son los que están generando la
tecnología y 'la y viceversa también no
entonces entender por qué se dan las
tendencias más allá de conocer las
tendencias es también algo que nos hacen
fallar cuando hacemos trabajo de
prospectiva y la última es porque nos
enfocamos demasiado en el futuro esto es
real ya para qué voy a diseñar mi futuro
y en qué tiempo como yo les decía en mi
gráfica que pase no una visión diez años
bueno hay quien es lo mejor necesita más
por el tipo de proyecto esto es algo que
decidimos cada uno dependiendo del
proyecto pero hay que buscar un
equilibrio y hay que verlo así entre más
nos alargamos
más se abre el cono de incertidumbre y
más tableros de control tendríamos que
tener para estar monitoreando cómo van a
evolucionar estas tendencias y
justamente ahí es donde se diseñan los
escenarios alternativos
entonces encuentra en el punto medio el
tiempo es algo muy importante
bueno si podemos hacer prospectiva y
debemos hacer prospectiva la prospectiva
justamente es esto es un puente entre el
hoy y lo urgente que nos ayuda a
determinar el mañana y las aspiraciones
de lo que queremos que suceda mañana eso
es prospectiva y esa es la unión y la
paradoja del futuro y porque el futuro
importa hoy
entonces qué vamos a hacer mañana porque
la única certeza que tengo para ustedes
es que mañana no se va a aparecer al día
de hoy muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]